It's only 64GB, it's nice to have an extra one.
Especially since if you're gonna take videos, one video is like 5GB.
It's completely justifiable.
What's next?
If there is a person, if there is a person, you can understand the language.
I can help you is Kosuke's mom.
Because that's something that you don't know about.
Kosuke-san has his brother.
Do you know that?
No, I mean yes, I did. He has multiple brothers.
No, only one brother.
And do you know what he...
Destiny?
No.
I don't know the details, but I know because he attended our wedding.
And he had a kind of ATSD.
And his life was completely different to Kosuke's.
Because Kosuke-san also has his own limitations.
But he can manage to, you know, to be enjoying his life a lot.
He can manage to be a lot of people.
I have tickets or not.
No.
So you are leaving on 23rd.
I mean, I have to.
I haven't done it yet because they're always putting me on hold.
I always get cut off and it takes so long that I end up not doing it.
What time do you do at 23rd?
8am or something.
I physically can't.
I have to change it.
It's not an option.
Because if I try to go at this flight, I'll be stranded because it's not enough time for me to lay over.
So it's not an option.
I have to change it.
I just haven't done it yet.
So I'll do it either tonight or tomorrow.
And why don't do that?
Because now it's closed.
It's not closed.
Is Asiana?
Yeah.
Asiana has here and Delta.
Asiana has here and Delta have here.